yeah hello and welcome to another video
covering a game from the 45 45 legal
niches this is leighton whacker playing
medknow key so this is a very sharp game
actually we'll see what happens it's a
post offense named davon Slovenian
player meisa I think tips there's even
the tilt memorial tournament I tried to
play that tournament once but it didn't
fit my schedule you know I travel
slovenia quite often so that would have
been nice but it didn't work out so okay
this is the first offense and a white
player goes for Bishop f4 this is a
somewhat unconventional move but not bad
at all it just needs to be followed up
correctly it's a normal developing move
of course Bishop g7 and now why play to
move age three I'm not so happy with
this move as it is not clear yet then
white needs this in any way this can
often be an option but do you need that
currently night h5 is not a threat so I
think I would have preferred to just
like windy to attending this I'll play
Knight f3 which can never be a bad move
just develop for example castles and
Queen d2 and whites position is quite
flexible you can still play for quick a
long castle but we can also play Bishop
h6 and just play Bishop d3 in this kind
of way h3 of the potential loss of tempo
it's not clear that this is a necessary
move so capsules Queen d2 9 a-6 yeah
this development are black on the year
on the rim is an interesting way to play
repairing c5 the media c5 sometimes d
tasty 5 is an
and you don't probably want to play this
position so light asics intends to play
c5 and then indicator of a capture to
try to recapture with the night so wyd
now played long castles possible however
after c5 which was likes intention
anyway white now has to be quite them
yeah quite cautious he should not do
what he's doing now and probably he has
to play something like captures on c5
yeah my eggs and then something like f3
this is probably quite okay for black
but it is still on better to play that
compared to what the white player did
maybe even bit should be three on a
stronger move then they can move in the
game white took on a six the bishop on
f1 captures the night in this particular
position this move is even technically
problematic on however I wanted to state
that in general taking the a69 with the
m1 bishop is this very rarely a good
idea I mean you see this kind of
situation quite often that the night
gets developed yonder and the edge of
the board and a bishop is simply usually
stronger than the night on a six the
damage to blacks pawn structure
potentially isn't all that much of a
problem as the B file gets opened up in
this precise position the problem is
more technically as black Chuck
correctly on the form this is the right
to reply and much stronger than just
recapturing I just wanted to mention
that besides this technical issue rarely
rarely a good idea to take the night on
a six so here please like to go on d4
and this is a nice move the night is
attacked and the bishop is still hanging
and white now probably had to take on d4
with the Queen
and it's not such a nice position to be
in but probably is the right move here
black has a good choice between taking
just taking on a six and playing nine h5
those moves i think are good here you
have to see that black has to be antsy
file open against white cane and Bishop
d7 can also be putting some pressure or
put some pressure on the porn but also
there should be six planets unpainted
there should be six screen 85 that looks
pretty strong black also have this move
which is probably I you ibly even
stronger yet another intermediate move
attacking the Queen and attacking the
bishop so probably Queen will go and now
take with the night on a form this
position is absolutely terrible for what
he's got two lights against two
absolutely raging bishops and B and C
file again they're open that it's
probably those two lost this position I
mean you know it doesn't look all that
bad maybe at the moment but just a
couple of moves later and see how
quickly would be eight Queen here or to
be six and it all comes with temple this
is terrible reading that is probably for
why to just drop this back and yeah
here's some 96 and black will be also
very happy he's got the the bishop pair
and charges on the queenside so still
this is what white should have done he
played this move please and after that
the position becomes almost lost like to
convey three pillars Queen takes and
Knight takes e4 so white has lost the
big sent upon and yeah also the power of
this Bishop becomes please enormous now
Queen III and here's a black player
missed a good opportunity the move that
he played was perfectly okay I mean it
kept
a good advantage but with the right move
yeah blacks position becomes absolutely
overwhelming and this is an easy move to
miss the thing is we have this tendency
as human beings to be hopefully in fact
it's a good thing to have to be
systematic about things the queen is
attacking the light and we automatically
assume okay the night is attacks have to
move it away or I have to cover it or
maybe we get to the point let me say
again I could be a counter-attack but
the natural tendency is to play what
metal okie did just retrieve the night
however there was a much stronger move
and here it is going to be sick and this
is something that can easily be missed
it's a counter-attack note that it also
looks at the White Queen first of all
this is not playable because after
Bishop f5 White has a huge problem yes
the cream going if you go to e2 to keep
c2 covered then clean be to King King d2
yes and so on leads to an absolutely
decisive attack there is no way for y to
survive this one after the bishop go see
if you don't cover see to it gets even
worse as black ya can take everything
here yeah and these are billion pawns up
and Evan attack the move Queen B six
bases in throwing was very strong
because what actually has to take and
then after the Queen trade black is in
fantastic shape now he's got an extra
pawn an extra sent upon very nice might
so why have to lose some time and firm
initiative for example after Bishop e3
the movie should be six is good yeah
those probably have to trade and then
again x2 hangs and
a 2 X 0 never run a bit of the wrong
arrow so here arrow yeah it's very good
for Black Knight f6 is not a terribly
bad move which is that Queen B 6 was
much more powerful after trading Quincy
also we'd use some any streaming link
potential a little bit yeah why plate 9
a-3 developing and now three like when
b6 this is a bit of a conservative move
it seems that he just wanted to prepare
bishop to be seven however i think what
black should do is play more ambitiously
b5 was a good good choice is why it
takes this group b 8 will be trouble
here for example please now the bishop
move black can already take this yes
King takes 95 now is a nice discover
check and the Queen gets lost so it's
very difficult now I mean why
theoretically speaking can cover this
bishop but after a six there's the same
story so wyd cannot actually take this
pawn and if you cannot take this pawn
it's a good move yeah it getting it gets
the same thing going with the bishop but
also expands quickly so like here black
has an attack here it's no fun v6 is a
bit too passive b5 was you are not just
like sitting on the extra pond actually
using the attacking potential rookie
won't you yeah and now black girls made
a mistake yeah this is a text and again
the best solution is not to like cover
the attack pawn or change something yeah
play something personally but to do a
counter-attack you should have played
clean 270 m
so that creamy 7i can be answered by the
capture and here like after we should be
three like still has the choice what he
wants to play if I've here for example
is possible in the game he immediately
plate is five but here the problem is
then white now can take on in five there
is opinion yeah look and greener yeah
facing each other on the D farm yeah
white can take on inside with the night
and enter bishop or all the bishop in
the game light xe5 was played the move
Bishop takes you fire forever I think
was stronger got a couple of lines to
look at it looks a little bit like a
self then after rupee eight but Bishop
takes f6 is actually blundering what
winning a piece for white or black
blundered and you can do a quick count
bleck is appealed down rook e8 is not
possible let him play something like
Queen since seven here essentially
double attacking but this is also quite
good for white you can take on at six
hey I'm sorry and play Queen chair for
looking at those and covering the bishop
here and probably right as a little bit
better yeah it's an important form that
he regained and he's got some blue some
nice piece activity the ambition cake c5
was definitely a good option that was
possible because black plate not so
welcomed in five instead the light hook
but now all of a sudden Queens to seven
habits which is good morally by men low
key now it's tricky for white if the
light moves somewhere then the Queen can
take the bishop something like that
there is only one thing that what can do
yeah yeah sacrifice on f7 may okay
sacrifice it's not a sacrifice as light
is not
two down but yeah take on itself got
those captures and now it's a wide to
move an absolutely critical position if
we do it just account we see that
material wise things are equal why does
God who can pawn against two minor
pieces on the black side yeah six bones
both five and because they look against
two pieces yeah wipe now has a couple of
moves that that he can play probably um
here bishop age six was an option in the
game the pawn on d6 was taken Bishop age
six I think it's quite interesting what
an important point is that black um
should he decide to take is in real
trouble takes King takes rook t6 here
white threatens very strongly Queen to
e7 or sometimes Luke takes rook takes
Knight and this is attract losing for
black he has a hard time here to keep
the material for example is Bishop f5
there is clean d form all kinds of
threats or 345 here um wine is winning
not is not easy for for black you can
try to get on checks but what can play
c3 and now again he has no defense it
doesn't look that terrible but how do
you defend at the end you have something
like we napped five there's just green
37 and next move white will take here
over the Queen now like here you can
just take with the Queen
so Bishop h6 was an interesting choice
however black does not have to take on a
two of course you can play other stuff
for example I catches Desmond then that
slightly let's say d5 orbit at five spot
but most come into consideration here
the situation is not quite clear to me
our material wise slide is not in bad
shape and something like f3 here and
then the stand maybe g4 h4 h5 white
might get something going here against
the king it feels firm like white is not
risking very much it's a good option i
think visual 86 and critics a2 is not a
move that is entirely unloading also
some some players might go for that
Bishop t6 was played in the game and
this is okay like objectively speaking
but tough very tough to play we'll see
black took on a to this is now
impossible not a bad move at all right
now has a very very narrow path to an OK
position and the first move played for
what is correct he played 23 attacking
the rook in the corner and yes in the
loop has no way to know no way to run so
it is essentially trapped on a eight in
a way so what to do now for black like
yeah played the check which is the best
move and here the the whiter play had to
find the right solution he plays Bishop
f4 which is wrong what in fact is okay
is the knots or surgical looking move
rookie and free the thing is give black
rep's this now and ft x ii we attack as
why we attack two pieces here and a
black has a hard time he cannot give up
the roofer in the corner what should he
do the best solution is to check give
checks here
and why cannot deviate he has to go back
something like that is not going to work
like a the peas up or even worse go
there when you're like gets this look
into the game here with the temple yeah
so this is a draw in fact the move look
III would have led to a draw quite funny
one Bishop f4 was played in the game and
this now should have lost it since lost
the game however oh my house a mess as
usual and here black had a winning
tactic that was unfortunately for my
player miss ya what was blacks best move
now you always have to check for our
dependencies and possession where is
like if pisem in a way pinned or tied to
a certain job and here you see that this
is a critical diagonal and the white
queen is currently the only p is
covering this if the White Queen
wouldn't cover the Bishop Bishop takes
therefore would be a disaster and this
was the way to use this fact very nice
the queen is attacked and can definitely
not take em here yes black will be
nearly so where's the Queen going you
can go here but after something like
that yeah like wings yeah pretty easily
or after Bishop e7 the Queen might go to
e3 but here 94 is strong threatening
mate well like position is excellent
something like c3 you can just go Bishop
yourself and then continue to attack but
should be seven was extremely strong and
also I mean it's a move that besides the
technical points it's just perfectly
coordinating black it's coming out with
a temple covering the look
it's a great move black and see that he
gave the check King be too and now check
again mc3 yeah now yeah after the trade
it's black smooth and now he only has
one way to play this is a text and the
way to do it was Bishop f5 preparing
potentially looked the aid and just
activating miss Bishop here after for
example g-form like is ok now if you
give the check in King it to you can
click we near I'm sorry or queen I'm
sorry what can I not hear ya this is the
bad move i want to attack this as well
yeah here for example like it's totally
fun it's a very technical position of
course so you can easily screw things up
note that this is covered they are very
tactical but it seems that black is fine
in the game the black did not play
Bishop at five but the check and this in
fact seems to lose the game King see one
Queen to f7 yeah rooty a check ordered
and now we see right here White has
excellent momentum the rukon d8 you have
put some pressure here on the edge rank
and blacks King is under under severe
pressure right now plate queen d 6 which
is correct and King age 6 yeah blackest
is really desperate so what's going on
here white now made a pretty big mistake
here the big thing is that white has an
attack on the black king and you should
definitely not a siege it trade queens
with queen of age he probably had some
miscalculation they are thinking that he
was winning
peace what does win ian is the move
rookie 7 attacking the Queen and we see
I mean where's the black queen supposed
to go it's not like it has many squares
for example something like here what can
just take sorry ok why can just take the
night there is no check nothing so black
has to do something yeah something else
what is there I really don't see it
something like this there are some fancy
solutions here for like the computer
gives yes but this is something that is
not necessary you can also just take
here and just be up tons of material so
it's a bit mysterious what prompted
white not to play will be seven there's
not even not even checks here like maybe
this one but you grab him and this is
just Jenny one single check that the
Queen has so not could not sure rookie
seven was the most logical looking move
and it does win this was trained in the
game may be wise the word players
thought that it would win with this as
well but this in fact is not the case
King g7 rooty 8 and now the strong move
King f7 and rookie 70 is prevented now
do account it's porn and rook against
two minor pieces this thing is not an
advantage for white do you follow the
plate there we going to look trade and
now g5 plate / black yeah and here right
now has to be um yeah alert what black
wants to do ideally is to grab all the
ports and why do I think is the one who
needs to be careful
and I mean he should try to make a draw
here if he finds something that draws he
should do it so he played this move now
I think the idea attacking g5 is not bad
at all but I wondered why didn't he go
with H form it's almost the same idea
just using the less valuable pawn for it
I think H fourth will probably lead to a
draw at the end Black takes g5 and we
see after a night move oops oops they're
both can take it we should be fourth
actually the best move him like should
give up this piece after the capture the
likelihood of draw here is fairly high
f3 ship g6 and like a white group is
coming around I think this is almost
certainly going to end in a draw the
computer gives some long line that ends
with some repetition and four is risky
the idea is somewhat similar but it
doesn't doesn't quite work out just gets
taken king e cigs and now I have to
watch out for the airport this is the
thing things are still probably ok but
now by now you have to be very precise
g6 was played King be one was probably
better King you too but the main thing
is coming here after Bishop inform and
white can still play the new gauge for
here and be ok note that black has this
so look at four there's a fork now but
after G 393 Kingda to king of seventh
book g-form this is not the totally
clear situation probably its own ends
and then some draw white somewhat
inexplicably now took on d7 and edges
just loses it just doesn't work takes
seven and like a stopping this and it's
just that yeah like will pick up this
for nothing now why tried a couple of my
moves between yeah he's quick enough him
okay so an easy win from here the
airport is to kept from Los the bishop
covers the promotion square so an
absolute layer big struggle both sides
had had spots where they could have won
and all in all this kind of game
probably should Pedro at the end but
here yeah black was ultimately
successful he was the first to have a
key advantage in the game so maybe there
are some some sort of justice there
however there were clear opportunities
for white later most of the size of my
fellows there was this situation here
yeah we're somehow Lucas heaven was not
played with just wings on the spot it
was the cleanest or the clearest moment
in the game to do the two decided yeah I
think an interesting game to watch I
hope you liked my coverage thanks for
watching